وسط كل الخراب الذي احدثته المعارك في
سوريا هناك عامل قاتل اخر يفتك بصمت وسط
ضوضاء الفوضى واول ضحاياه الاكثر ضعفا في
هذا الفيديو الذي نشره نشطاء المعارضه على
يوتيوب يكافح ابراهيم ذو العامين ونصف
للبقاء على قيد الحياه جسده لا يحتمل
الطعام الصلب ويستطيع هضم الحليب فقط
ولكنه غير متوفر
له تواصلنا مع طبيب الاطفال ابو سامر في
سوريا عبر سكايب الذي اشرف على علاج
ابراهيم ناني منها عند الاطفال بسبب غياب
تام للمواد الغذائيه وحتى المواد الغذائيه
الصناعيه وحتى البدائل نحن استنفذنا كل
مخزونات المنزليه بالمدينه اغلب سكان
منطقه معضم الشام هربوا منها ولكن من بين
ال 15000 الذين بقوا هناك ما يقارب 5000
طفل بينهم تحت الحصار لاشهر من قبل قوات
النظام وهم مقطوع عن كل المساعدات مطالبات
الصليب الاحمر بالدخول الى سوريا رفضت
مرارا الاف السوريين يعيشون نفس حاله
الحصار في مناطق مختلفه من البلاد
والدبابات تتواجد في محيط هذه المنطقه
باكملها ما عدا طريق واحد فقط لكنه خطير
جدا وبسبب الخيار الصعب بين الحصول على
الاسلحه او الطعام تقول قوات المعارضه
انها تضطر لاختيار السلاح والا سيتعرضون
للقتل جميعا من النظام عمار ذو التاسعه
مصاب باضطراب عصبي ولم يتوفر الغذاء
والدواء المناسبان للحفاظ على حالته
الصحيه المتدهوره
فعلا الناس وصلت لمرحله انه تاكل اوراق
الشجر لحتى
تسد
الجوع يعني الكبير ممكن يدبر حاله ممكن
يقبل انه ياكون على الخضروات المزروعه
منزليا وهي بتعرفي انت عندك يعني اطلاعات
طبيه هي لا تغني ولا تسمن عن ج يعني بتعطي
اما عماد فاجرته عمليه استئصال لجزء من
امعائه قبل شهرين بعد اصابته بشذ في الجزء
العلوي من جسده لكن لم توجد طريقه لتوفير
الاحماض الامينيه والبروتينات اللازمه
لتعافيهم قضى في نفس اليوم الذي تحدثنا
فيه الى الطبيب ولا يمكننا ان نتاكد من
صحه هذه المقاطع او سبب وفاه الاطفال بشكل
مستقل ولا يمكن للصليب الاحمر كذلك تاكيد
اسباب الوفاه شح الطعام او انعدامه وغياب
الادويه يمنعان اي شخص مصاب بحاله مرضيه
من مقاومتها واذا لم تفك قوات النظام
الحصار يقول الاطباء ان هذه ستكون البدايه
فقط